To return any data as output and use it
outside function definitions like we want to do with the value of currentLikes,
I'll have to do two things.
The first thing is I have to change the return type,
which is now void to the output type I expect to be returned.
And return types are just types of variables,
strings, integers, doubles and so on.
In this case, we know you want to return a currentLikes variable,
which is in int value so we'll change the return type from void to int.
The second thing we need to do is to return the value of
the int of our currentLikes in a return statement.
The return statement is just a line of code
at the end of a function definition that says,
return, followed by the value you want to output.
In this case, that's the value of currentLikes so our return statement is just,
return currentLikes followed by a semi-colon.
Now, because I've included the correct return type and the return statement,
when I call this function,
it will output the value of currentLikes
and we'll be able to use this output value in other function calls.
Here's our function call from before that adds to
the initial zero value of our currentLikes since our boolean like argument is true.
This function call, will increase
our current initial likes from 0 to 1 and it will also return this value.
I can now store the returned output of this function call as an int variable,
which I'll call returnedLikes.
This function call, outputs the value 1 and then I can store that in a variable.
Now the output of likePhoto gives us access to the return value of currentLikes.
Once we store this output in a variable,
I can use it just like I would any other invariable.
This goes for any function that returns a value like this.
The function call should be used in the same way that its return type is used.
For likePhoto, I can use this returned int value,
which is equal to 1 in this case,
to automatically keep track of the likes a photo gets.
For our second function call,
instead of typing in 0 or 1 for our currentLikes,
I can just pass in the returnedLikes and it will keep track of
the likes no matter what the value of our first function call outputs.
Now every call to like photo will return the latest number of likes.
This second call will return an updated number
of currentLikes and I'll store that in another variable,
which I'll call int totalLikes.
Let's see how this works.
When our first call has a true boolean like argument value,
the returnedLikes will be equal to 1
and this value will be passed into our second function call.
Our second function call,
also has a boolean value true here so it will increase
its currentLikes argument by 1 and we expect a total value of 2 to be returned.
Our first function call returns a value of 1 currentLike and our second,
returns a value of 2, which is correct.
But if the first call has its boolean like value set to false,
the returnedLikes will be equal to 0.
Our second call still has a boolean value of
true so it should increase the returnedLikes by 1.
This time, after our first function call,
the returnedLikes are zero and after our second function call,
our totalLikes are 1 and that's correct.
The totalLikes are correct each time and we didn't have
to change anything about our second function call at all.
Making functions that return data is really useful when you want
to use that return value in another program or a function call,
instead of just printing it out to the screen.
Let's get more practice recognizing and writing return statements.